that's the problem with trying to tell
fantasy from reality
they're both ridiculous
[Music]
hey it's uh christmas special time
and that means that we've arrived at
last
christmas and no i'm not gonna start
singing that song
uh but you know what
i don't remember where i put this when i
did my ranking of christmas specials
but i might have undervalued it this is
quite good
especially for a christmas special and i
say that as someone who
more often than not doesn't like the
christmas specials i don't like
the jokey vibe to them but something
about the premise here despite the fact
that the
very first tonal shift in the episode is
a little bit jarring i'll identify that
in a minute
but for the most part the integration of
some kind of horrific notions
oh and some heavy emotional moments
along with the insanity of
santa just being there
and for me it works they
after that first jarring gear shift it
does pretty well
so um let let me actually address that
gear shift
so it opens with clara
you know finding santa on her roof
which is fine because it sets up nick
frost as santa and his elves
all of whom are great nick frost
especially
he is a perfect santa especially for
this story
he's just great and i love the way these
characters interact both with each other
and with everybody else i love how
whatever the typical
well how can santa be real because of x
questions come up
they just talk about it so
matter-of-factly
it's like where do you think all those
presents came from my parents oh
yeah one day out of nowhere
because they love you so much
it's a lovely story dear yeah but it's
time to start living
in the real world yeah i love that i
love the way
because so much more is answered not in
the words that they say to
explain how santa works but just with
the tone they adopt whenever it comes up
and that just sells it
beautifully so i love all that but then
we get to the
outpost at the north pole and
things they try to ease us in
with you know this woman going in and
having music in her ears kind of dancing
to distract herself so that
her thoughts don't wake up the dream
crabs uh
but then pretty harshly it goes
horrific like these things are i mean
it gets called out flat out that they
resemble the face huggers
the horror movie alien there's a horror
movie called alien
that's really offensive no wonder
everyone keeps invading you but like
they're
gooey and it's tense and they're kind of
horrific and
it's a little bit odd because i like i'm
not sure
i think i'd have to see it but
my instinct is to say it would have
flowed better starting more serious
introducing the ridiculous element as
opposed to starting ridiculous and then
introducing the horror element
because this is setting your initial
tone so if you then
darken it it can be a little bit whoa
wait a minute
unless like that sudden shift is the
point i'm not sure it was in this case
whereas if you start with a darker tone
and introduce something more
light-hearted
that's not necessarily marking a total
shift of the thing it me it just means
lighthearted element in dark scenario
which you get a lot more often
so but after that initial
grinding of gears and the shifting of
tones
it moves pretty well between those
two spaces and keeping everything at a
good pace
this thing this thing is pretty dang
good and it tracks
so far as i could figure it it does
track
with all of the wakings up in the layers
of thing i mean it's inception meets
alien basically i think inception had
happened by now
and it it does all track except for
the very last one which doesn't
fail to track it just kind of comes out
of nowhere and
we'll come back to that so we've got
ourselves an isolated not quite
base under siege set up because
technically the aliens are already
inside
uh so i i but i do like i i like the
vibe
of those setups i like always have going
back to you know
second doctor when base under siege
became almost the norm
like i do just enjoy that i enjoy that
feel
and this has it quite well and it does a
good job
of giving us the little ways of
indicating the dreams like i
i really i thought it was brilliantly
clever
the the doctor giving out the four
manuals to all four of them and
and you know picking a random page read
them all out because if we're in a dream
those won't match and that was that was
a cool clever way of doing it
and sort of marking the uh the dreams
the uh hiding something in plain sight
the fact that there were only four
manuals there were only four of them but
then who the heck are the four
who already are head are head grabbed so
you know there's it's it's pretty well
laid out
and and smoothly handled uh the
supporting cast is
solid not i mean aside from nick frost
not particularly exceptional
i do really love that nick frost when he
enters at the base he comes in like a
total badass
if you're gonna do santa's a badass he
really
really nails it it's just so good and i
and i love his bickering with the doctor
reminds me a little bit of what happened
with the doctor in robin hood which
makes sense because again
you know a person who's not supposed to
be real
they seem they have a way of getting
under this doctor's skin particularly
i'm seeming to notice
but as far as the crew at the base there
fine
that all of them have a good little beat
somewhere along the line
but let's talk about clara and
the doctor because there's a couple of
slightly odd bits here and there and
there are some things that really work
one of the odd things is when clara
first gets onto the tardis
it's treated like a big deal and she has
this whole
i'm back here again which
like in context theoretically a bunch of
time has passed
and i forget how early in the year
the episodes would have stopped airing
it would be presumably some months
from when uh death and heaven air to win
this year so there has been
time passed but there's been no stories
in between
so it doesn't feel momentous the way
that they're presenting it
if there had been like i didn't a series
without clara and then brought her back
for this
that would warrant that momentousness or
heck even just a couple of
episodes where the doctor was on his own
just something to
put in between because otherwise it
feels like yeah there's been a passage
of time but
in terms of the stories we've seen she's
right back
so that was an odd thing to play up as a
big moment
i have mixed feelings about addressing
the fact that the doctor didn't know
danny had died
like on the one hand that makes sense
and i actually think initially that
moment is played well but then that
means that they have to actually call
out the fact that clara lied to him
and he lied to clara and why they did it
and i don't like that
not because it's bad or that the
interpretation of what they say and why
they did it is wrong
like no that's totally why they did that
uh in each case
but like do you not trust your audience
was there a big rush of like online
debate of
why did the doctor lie to clara why did
carl like was that a question you felt
the need to answer
because to me it seemed immensely
self-evident why each of them lied to
the other
so taking a minute to lay out why
it's i i don't i don't know why they
felt the need to do that that's it i do
like
i like that danny in the dream is
true today to what danny was when he was
alive in that
he is prepared to stand up to the doctor
to push claire to do what is best for
her even if
it's something that she doesn't want to
do
so i it felt like a good
sort of memorial to the character of
danny pink i thought that was that was
pretty well done
there's a moment that i i'm not sure i
don't like it and especially given
what the show will ultimately end up
doing with the doctor in clara
i do have to admit this actually tracks
but it's still a weird moment to me
which is once they realize that clara
has been
you know gotten the thing uh and
they're looking at the doctor's first
question is how do we kill it
and that's just again i'm not someone
who's like the doctor would never
know the doctor has killed depending on
which doctor
either through direct action or through
inaction or
through setting things up so that the
villains destroyed themselves but like
the doctor's not above that
but it's just weird to me that so quick
how do we kill it what
but at the same time like i said this
actually does make a fair amount of
sense
because knowing how and i i mentioned
this before how
toxic their relationship is and how
being around each other pushes each of
them to
do things that are not good for them as
people so it does track
but then we've got the ending so
after the waking up the multiple layers
rescued by santa which is great by the
the slave riding does that scene goes on
a little longer
than it should i feel like they might
have tried to pad an extra
30 seconds to a minute into that scene
but
i i still like it i like the tone i like
the vibe it's nicely celebratory
it's it's just sweet i enjoy it and then
the doctor
wakes up and goes to get clara
and she's old
which was properly set up because the
doctor said you know we'll go back to
our own
times in dreams time travel is possible
and so he'd already set up the
possibility that they weren't all from
the exact same point in time
and he goes and sees her and they have
this really
nice scene this wonderful bonding scene
of the doctor with this old version of
clara that he does not treat any
differently
and that she gets to share with him
you know some of her joys and some of
her pain that she's had since the last
time she saw him
but it's so evidently clear that she's
happy to see him now
i really like that scene and it would
have been
a fantastic utterly beautiful
way to sign off clara and have her exit
at that point and that's what it was
supposed to be
so i i've done a little bit
don't tell anyone i did a little bit of
research
but i did i did look a little bit into
it because i i've had it said to me
for a while that you know she was going
to leave and from what i can
what i could find looking into it yeah
well not exactly
she was waffling back and forth as to
whether or not she was going to
stick around and she was leaning towards
no and then when they did the table read
for this
episode she basically changed her mind
and said no i want to stay
and thus we have what does rightfully
feel like the very tacked on
oh one extra layer that doesn't totally
make sense because we're just gonna have
the doctor wake up exactly where it was
that he woke up
last time so and which again like it
doesn't fail a logic test it's just like
you can feel the tactile nature of it
you can feel the kind of
i don't want to say lazy but rushed the
rushed
change in order to not have old clara be
the end for clara oswald
and that annoys me because that would
have been a really beautiful ending
she's now had two really good exit
points and she didn't leave
she will have a third really good exit
point
after which she will still come back
we'll get there but
and accepting that it's not
terrible but you know the
the word was that they were looking at
fay marseille
who played shona to possib this wasn't
confirmed yet she i don't think she'd
signed anything yet but they were
considering bringing her back
to play the companion
next in the next season if clara hadn't
come back
and you kind of get a little bit of the
vibe of what would ultimately become
bill potts which is a very ordinary
person
um and she couldn't she had a similar
vibe
you know she wants to do more with her
life she wants to experience more but
she's
just has a very ordinary dull boring
life and bill potts
has a little bit of that element so i i
feel like
the things that would have been part of
shona had she become the companion got
uh mixed into bill when that character
was created
and also there's a very funny moment
because at this point that actress is
best known as the waif from game of
thrones
and when she's looking at her checklist
of what she plans to do on christmas day
one of the things on there is thrones
marathon
i don't know i don't think she would
have shot her part in game of thrones
yet she might have been cast already so
that
that was either a an awesome prediction
or an inside joke because she already
knew she was going to be on there i'm
not sure which it is either way
i i like that i like that little bit
but yeah the flaws in this thing are
pretty minor
that initial sort of gear shift when the
tone
changes but after that the gear shifts
work pretty well
solid performance work all across the
board the
the final resolution is a little tacked
on especially given how much the
preceding scene like
really felt like a good proper end but
other than that
this is really solid definitely one of
the better
christmas episodes and one that i really
should make a point
of re-watching more than i do so
last christmas i gave you my hearts ah
good
dang it okay anyways have you rewatched
it lately what'd you think about
whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it i've got all sorts of
stuff
in links down there as well i have merch
i am on
twitter i have a patreon that's kind of
the big one that is what is currently
covering my bills
um but you know even if you're not able
to do that
liking subscribing sharing all of those
help me out
and just realize that while i'd
appreciate it you don't
have to end of the day you're the
council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you